اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح جنوب القطاع
اهلا بكم محكمه العدل الدوليه تعقد اولى
جلساتها بشان الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا ضد اسرائيل ووفد يستعرض الادله
على الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه ويقول ان نيه
ارتكاب الاباده الجماعيه متوفره على اعلى
المستويات السياسيه والعسكريه ويطالب
المحكمه بمنع افعال الاباده الجماعيه في
من خلال التدابير المؤقته كتائب القسام
تقول انها استهدفت غرفه قياده اسرائيليه
ودمرت اليات عده واوقعت قوه اسرائيليه بين
قتيل وجريح وسرايا القدس تقول انها قصفت
بالهاون تجمعا للقوات الاسرائيليه في بني
سهيلا في حين قال رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
ان القتال في غزه معقد
للغايه مصادر اسرائيليه ت يقول ان
اجتماعات وزير الخارجيه الامريكي مع
الاسرائيليين كانت متوتره وانه ابلغهم ان
لدى الفلسطينيين طموحات يجب تقبلها بلينكن
قال ان الدوله الفلسطينيه يجب ان تكون
جزءا من اي جهود تكامل او تطبيع بين
اسرائيل وجيرانها في الشرق الاوسط غداه
ادانه مجلس الامن هجمات الحوثيين على
السفن في البحر الاحمر بريطانيا تعلن تعرض
سفينه لحادث قباله سواحل عمان وتغيير
مسارها نحو المياه الاقليميه الايرانيه
وجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين تؤكد سلامه
الملاحه في المنطقه مطالبه بعدم الانجرار
وراء ما سمتها الادعاءات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه الى
اللقاء